this contest arena's PT is certain the
version of said twins ds3 that she's
trying out is a woman's car one clue is
a picture of a font called Leon on the
key this little deer is the logo of
French designer Ynez Dolores on she was
a model and an inspiration for Karl
Lagerfeld and then became a fashion
designer herself
now she's partnered with su twins
high-end sub brand es to create a new
look for the ds3
on the outside it's identifiable by the
red mirrors the red wheel hub logos and
the blue white and red striped rim
inspired by old airmail envelopes
running along the rear windshields
bottom edge
[Music]
[Applause]
the opal white roof with a third brake
light integrated in the rear spoiler
since a modern contrast to the dark blue
body
[Music]
[Music]
buyers can choose between a 73 kilowatt
engine with automatic transmission and
96 kilowatts with a six-speed manual
transmission we tested the stronger
gasoline-powered engine it pulls the car
from 0 to 100 km/h in 8.9 seconds the
230 Newton meters maximum torque come
into play from upwards of 1,750 revs per
minute and give the little D s plenty of
zip
eNOS thinks the ninety six kilowatt
engine is ideal for the car even in
sixth gear she had enough power and
reserve to make driving on the Autobahn
fun the designer edition is also
available as a convertible
a soft black fabric top takes the place
of the white roof
the special edition is limited to only
200 cars worldwide that works out to
just ten hardtop and 15 convertible
versions of the nearly 4 metre long
super mini for the German market
exclusive design has its price our test
vehicle costs twenty-seven thousand
three hundred seventy euros in Germany
that's roughly five thousand euros more
than the best-equipped normal ds3 model
with an identical motor the designer has
left her signature on the interior as
well
the granite blue grained leather seats
pick up on the three color airmail theme
the carpet mats are edged with the same
three colored cord the bright red
accents seen outside appears again for
the entire length of the dashboard
penis realizes that design doesn't
necessarily follow logical rules for
instance even if the center console is
fitted with a touchscreen the menu
selections work by pressing buttons down
below and not along the sides as we
might expect the buttons for the
air-conditioning are right where they
belong
the indicator has a little round screen
of its own
[Music]
here this time the instrument cluster is
a bit too conventional for
enas taste she'd expected more from a
designer car dynamic indicators for
example that allow you to choose from a
range of designs Huzhou already offers
something along those lines in its 3000
AGT where the driver uses a little ruler
on the steering wheel to select the
style of instrument cluster
[Music]
but then the ds3 has a perfume dispenser
and an illuminated mirror set in the Sun
Visor Amos points out that while car
buyers normally pick out their
customization options from a catalog
Dee's Commission's a trendy designer and
gives the resulting special edition an
attractive name she thinks it goes
perfectly with ds's own philosophy after
all since when has positioned its sub
brand as a car maker that highly values
exclusive design
[Music]